I'm back [ __ ] it's Monday May
[ __ ] 5th the first Monday in
May will all start some [ __ ]
zero the church what's happened now is
brought to you by 12 flowers don't
forget to thank the real pros this
Mother's Day listen my wife is
tremendous Mother's Day we go all out of
the [ __ ] casa and ProFlowers will be
on the list it's coming up May 12th
don't forget where would you be without
your mother where would you be not you
know where you understand me ProFlowers
let you choose from a variety of
bouquets and visors that suit every mom
style all you got to do is pick the
delivery date right now you got a dozen
assorted roses for $19.99 you Amy double
the roses and get a premium vaz for just
$9.99 more that's what I'm talking about
visit proflowers.com click the
microphone on the upper right corner and
enter promo code write this down
happening H ap PE and ing that's
proflowers.com click the microphone use
code happening mother's Day is May 12th
so don't wait order like a pro and get
an amazing rose deal to thank all the
moms in your life this is tremendous cuz
if you like your mom you can send to
these white flowers and show up and if
you don't like your mom you can send to
these and then give her a call tell the
kids sick you ain't going close to that
[ __ ] a third husband and she married
back there you know I'm saying that's
what you need to hook up with Hector on
Sunday on Mother's Day you know if
things are gonna happen and the church
is also brought to you by CBD Lyon calm
listen no more buying CBD products in
the bodega made by some witch doctor in
the basement CBD Lyon is the way to go
they make CBD products from start to
finish
CBD Lyon has you covered and right now
the church family gets 20% off not even
ten twenty go to CBD line calm and check
out their third party lab results
yourself Church family gets 20% off when
you can write in church typing in CH you
are CH at check out who's better than
you Lee kick this [ __ ] meal
great the [ __ ] be back
I'm only home for are we gonna happen I
go back to the finish shootin a couple
days in New York City for starters it
was a great experience it's great to be
back I missed you [ __ ] on a
protip you know what's the weirdest
thing because when I got this movie and
the movie I got guys I could tell you I
can't tell you who's in the movie now
that ship like it takers you're from to
find out anyway it's out I guess there
was paparazzi taking pictures and one of
my pictures came out so people bother me
I'm in the Sopranos prequel the Sopranos
in 67 the many saints of Newark it's I
was very fortunate to get it and when I
got it I was happy but then I started
thinking about having me there for three
[ __ ] weeks plus I got another movie
that I'm gonna shoot in June thank God
it's not at the same time I thought I
had to shoot them both at the same time
but when I got the movie right away I
was happy for a few days and then I did
what every [ __ ] [ __ ] this I started
thinking about it and the more I thought
about it I didn't think I could survive
19 days without my wife and kid what am
I gonna do you know just a bunch of
negative [ __ ] comes into your mind when
something good happens and it happens at
every [ __ ] level as you notice I mean
just negative [ __ ] came in I'm not gonna
go I'm not gonna do well and thank God
for Tom pop on another one of my friends
that I talked to talked me into it
I agreed to do it now I'm very happy
because it's it was a life-changing
experience that I needed right now I've
been getting flat you ever get flat in
your [ __ ] life like it just flat
you'd go to work you do what you got to
do when you go home you go to work you
kind of become a machine and you look
for something but you don't know what it
is you know when you stop wasting time
now you have all this [ __ ] time to do
what you really want to do with your
life and sometimes you become flat yeah
you do a little writing you do this you
do that but this 24 hours in the [ __ ]
day you can't write it off damn you
can't do jumping jacks all day and you
can't sit around with your [ __ ]
friends all day you got to make forward
progress which is what I'm always doing
but at the same time I got to be honest
here I got a little [ __ ] bored like I
just got bored and this movie came up
and right away the fears come in yeah
and again I when I got on the plane I
was fine when I landed in New York
you know I had my anxieties my little
panic [ __ ] [ __ ] I got to the hotel
room and I started down myself blah blah
blah blah blah but the first night I had
to go to wardrobe and once I went to
wardrobe and I figured out exactly what
I was doing I was fine then I walked out
of wardrobe I had a hot dog right then
42nd Street and then about an hour later
when I got to the hotel about blocking
the hotel I saw a [ __ ] rat and I knew
I was home like once I started alright
that was the sign that I'm in the gutter
of life I'm back here where it all
started so I had a few days to go before
I shot and like I got that Monday and I
think I had to shoot Wednesday and
Friday the first week Wednesday and
Thursday because then Friday I went to
Minneapolis thank you for coming to the
shows with beam Bell ray and then that
Saturday was 4/20 with Milwaukee you
guys are great too sold that shows thank
you very much the City of Milwaukee it
was a great 4/20
somebody [ __ ] cosby'd me with a
[ __ ] edible and little walk a stir
don't know what it is and guess what I
don't give a [ __ ] he did a good job I
got [ __ ] up but I came the first week
I was just I was just frozen I didn't
know how to act so that Tuesday before I
did anything I took a [ __ ] uber up to
88th Street where I grew up when I came
you know and it was just overwhelming to
see the block where so much it happened
I mean this when I moved into this
apartment building I was three-quarters
[ __ ] and after I hit with the head
with a lunchbox and I started to
experience New York City and what it was
about I grew into my skin I became like
a little man man like I thought about
all the things my mom would make me do
like I haven't been moving with it I
walked up and stood in front of the
building and I was gonna take a picture
not [ __ ] but guess what I when I took
this trip I took it with the thing that
I didn't want to do podcasts I didn't
want to do a lot of stand-up comedy I
didn't want to book anything significant
like Nyack or a night in New York I just
wanted to work out so I did spots in
Dangerfield's real like 1012 people a
night just up there riffing [ __ ]
around just to keep the timing alive
and that that was it I didn't want to do
people's podcast I didn't want to be
running around I just wanted to focus on
this movie I was gonna have a lot on my
[ __ ] plate I don't think my agents
you know that's I told my agent don't
even talk to me about dates I don't want
to know nothing all I want to do is
focus on that [ __ ] movie I got a
great opportunity I gotta put on it
percent into it and I went up took my
old neighborhood and I walked around
then I went to the public school 166 I
crossed the street to the horse place I
never owned a horse there I was always
scared but I would go in there and steal
horseshoes what and sell out the kids
and [ __ ] for like a dollar 50 cents
whatever the [ __ ] it was in those days a
quarter is this the neighborhood of mr.
martini yeah mr. martini is named well I
saw mr. martinis house it's worth like a
half a [ __ ] billion dollars now it's
a redstone there's probably four kids
buried in the backyard place but it was
just so weird when I got from standing
in front of that building like I
remembered my mom would put a huge gold
chain on me and make me go out to see if
I would protect myself if somebody tried
to rob it like there was so many lessons
that came to me while I was standing in
front of that [ __ ] building and I
just walked around that was it I went up
to Hall worked like 93rd Street and then
I walked down like 79th Street like
stand of New York I looked around there
I saw the Caridad but I didn't want to
eat Chinese food because it's got a lot
of sodium and you blow up and you don't
want to be on camera [ __ ] bloated up
looking like [ __ ] Johnny Cheech so I
said [ __ ] it I only ate Chinese food on
Easter Sunday with the chance and I
finished up the first week in New York
was rough on the [ __ ] guy I only
worked out one time and I want to thank
inline Fitness for helping me work out
Adam and my man Jonathan and I also went
to King's Thai boxing down on thirty
[ __ ] sixth Street with my man Jay the
Dominican and my girl Carmen the Puerto
Rican from the [ __ ] Bronx they look
at the brother up I went there a few
times to keep in shape and to sweat out
all the [ __ ] sodium for the New York
food and once I went up to that [ __ ]
neighborhood and walked around that's
why I felt my balls like I was like okay
this is
- [ __ ] I am again this is where I came
from and then that night you know me
I'll hit Rudy's and cuz I parked the
first night so I jumped on the
[ __ ] ferry from the New York
Water Works there and took it in -
[ __ ] edge while we walking and then my
buddy picked me up and went to Rudy's
and we hung out and I told to take a
ride around that [ __ ] neighborhood
just to see what that was like anymore I
didn't go down to my mother's house or
around that area I just stayed up
lightly in North Bergen and I went home
early that night and you know the first
night when you're out of California
you're not gonna sleep you're not gonna
sleep because of the time change and so
I knew that going in that would give me
a night just to get a custom - you know
filming and I went on the [ __ ] set
Wednesday and it was there was a rough
day for me because I hadn't acted in a
movie you know movie and TV is
differently had an act in the movie in a
long time so the first day was type of
room
kind of rough for me I didn't know what
was going on really but one of the
actors I was watching him and he's
[ __ ] phenomenal and I just fed off
his energy in a way and then I got into
it and by the second day I was all the
[ __ ] away and you know I had tapped into
David chases mind
I mean here's a guy that put a
television show on that was the
blueprint for Breaking Bad you know our
sons of anarchy
king of thrones whatever the [ __ ] Game
of Thrones so he had something to bring
to the table it's really weird when you
work somebody of a high caliber you you
open your eyes like I didn't watch my
dailies but I watched the two minutes I
watched what the cameras look like and
[ __ ] and that's what it all came to me
of what the [ __ ] I was involved in like
I had to go sit down my blood pressure
had gone up like I'm involved in
something [ __ ] big and I'm telling
you guys I don't want it on social media
I'm telling you guys because I don't
want you guys to read it somewhere I'll
see that picture they put up with me
again and I don't want I want you to
hear from me I can't that's all I can
fill you him on I'm happy for you guys
because you bet on me and I came through
for you you know I'm saying so a year
from now
when the movie gets released you know
you're part of it because we've been
doing this podcasting like I've said
since day one this podcast you guys are
my psychiatry because you keep me in
[ __ ] check
you keep me working out you keep me
looking at things you keep me trying to
be sharper I take sixteen months in
between dates and cities so when I go
back that's a new experience for you
guys you don't saying but back to what
happened in New York you know when I was
walking around it all came back to me
you know where I had come from I have a
rule you know I like to travel for three
days especially when it comes to New
York because when I'm in New York longer
than three days it takes me a few days
to unwind like it takes me a little
longer because it takes me back that far
back like it takes me into Coco you know
when I was robbing and doing bad things
so after a few days I go my mind goes to
places it shouldn't [ __ ] go but in
the same thought Here I am on the movie
set and I thought about the stretch I
had made and I thought about the things
I had done
along the way to get like I was back
there in 93 grinding out guys I was a
[ __ ] open mic or wishing I could get
an audition you know and I took a comedy
class and I [ __ ] worked at the old
New Yor a comedy club and was I doing it
right or what it doesn't matter I was in
the struggle I was there I still
remember paying you know 40 hours to
park to audition for an improv troupe at
the Copacabana but I had know nothing
about I was at the wrong place at the
wrong time when I walked in there I
still think today that those people
Remember Who I am
they're laughing at me behind my back
because I wanted that and belong there
but that's not the here and now what was
wheelers that I saw my struggle back
there as something meaningful it wasn't
a waste those nine months I put into New
York weren't a waste because here I was
20-some years later in a major film and
that's a great [ __ ] feeling so even
though I was thinking about robbing the
hammock all across the street from the
high school and we know when I went down
side streets I thought about the people
I robbed on that block all the time I
crawled into this window
whatever I looked at the bar I used to
borrow money from the loan shark and
never pay him back and you know I looked
at all these things and it just
reflected of where the move I had made
in my life and how proud I should be but
I'm not I'm not because I was such a
piece of [ __ ] but I'm just trying to get
back now to just being normal
like I just want to be a regular [ __ ]
guy I don't want to do nothing I just
want to live my life regular I want to
be a good dad and a good husband go out
that way as long as I go out that way
I'm very [ __ ] happy but a lot of
things came to focus for me in New York
like even being a [ __ ] immigrant you
know like for years we've been living
here and you never heard the word
immigrant all sudden the last three
years you know we focus on immigrants
and what the [ __ ] going on I must have
taken 90 [ __ ] overs in New York the
last 10 19 days nine three you got a
figure four visit that I took so many
who beside made platinum-level damn
that's how many [ __ ] lubbers I cooked
in New York but I tell you what that was
probably the best part of my trip were
the Huber's because I got to ride you
know many white uber drivers pick me up
3-0 the whole time the whole time
dancing the whole time it was [ __ ]
third world nations couple Hindus and
[ __ ] Spanish people a couple Chinese
people the most inspiring was a girl
that picked me up in the heart of
Brooklyn at 2:00 in the [ __ ] morning
a Hindu girl she had been in this
country for one year you ready for this
one year and she was she spoke like she
had been here for 10 [ __ ] years she
said it was important to her to learn
English so she'd get the most out of her
stage so she could become an American
that [ __ ] cracked me like that
cracked me she said she was working at
an Indian restaurant she was getting 8
bucks an hour and she got sick and tired
of having a boss so she does uber from
12 to 9 6 nights a week and she crippled
her [ __ ] income and she says she
works nights because there's no traffic
it's better for a [ __ ] woman telling
me this
I'm like I know guys were scared to
drive uber at [ __ ] night here's his
little hundred ten pound little Indian
girl you know I was so [ __ ] blown
away from her I got picked up by [ __ ]
Arabs that that was so interesting to
speak to about why they were opening
like it's people who one day said [ __ ]
it if I'm gonna get [ __ ] in the ass
I'm gonna control my own destiny and
they make a schedule and they stick to
it I mean this guy was you know these
guys were telling me a little every time
I get him I'd ask him how long they've
been driving why they're driving and how
they liked it not one of them said they
hated it they picked their own hours
they were their own bosses I mean I
remember the [ __ ] day I realized you
could do that I was probably I was
before I got locked up I had this boss
named David Wain means that used to
always say I never want to live in a
world where I have to have a ceiling
over my income like I don't want to be
stuck at a certain [ __ ] income I want
every week to be an adventure yeah
there's 52 weeks you're not gonna make
$6,000 every [ __ ] week but even if
you make eight hundred it's better than
having your own boss I looked at all
these people that were immigrants that
figured out the real [ __ ] American Way
and I thought about all the [ __ ]
stiff some around out here the [ __ ]
bumpy's that are waiting for a [ __ ]
handout or they just you know and it
inspired me it inspired me the other day
I was talking to Deborah [ __ ] Lobster
she's [ __ ] oberon that [ __ ] don't
stop you know you can't stop Debra
[ __ ] help stir you gotta shoot it
with a [ __ ] bazooka you're not gonna
stop her you know so these are the
people that keep me [ __ ] going when I
spoke to all and look at I goof around
and all this [ __ ] but hey man the truth
is the [ __ ] truth these people bloom
that was the best part of being in New
York with you but the whole 19 days the
people that I spoke to Chinese I spoke
to this old Chinese guy that was a
[ __ ] engineer and he retired but he
[ __ ] wanted to do you take any cabs
not one I won't care Wow
not one cab by you but [ __ ]
everywhere I just thought it was easier
there was no drama and I figured out
that believe it or not you saved money
with uber you saved a lot of [ __ ]
money whatever bad I was saying when I
was spending on cars and [ __ ] it's
ridiculous it is [ __ ] ridiculous you
know I have a friend that has a car
service and I would call him up listen
when I to go to the airport I could get
there myself when you after you take a
six-hour flight you really don't want no
[ __ ] stories after I'm on a six-hour
[ __ ] flight I don't want to walk the
terminal [ __ ] 6 upstairs with three
bags of [ __ ] luggage from my legs are
all dead and uber and for the Yubel to
say 20 minutes and then you're out there
I'm in terminal e you know where you f I
put it down in the [ __ ] thing
and you said okay I put down US terminal
F and you said okay and now you're
calling me from [ __ ] II take a run
take a run it do to the guy at LAX the
other take a [ __ ] lap around I don't
give a [ __ ] at this point I'm not
carrying three [ __ ] bags one that
weighs [ __ ] 1000 pounds the terminal
[ __ ] he you know but besides that I
had no complaints I love Hoover I
[ __ ] love him I know that at the end
of the week I saw when I took a cab from
LAX to my house I saw what I was
spending yeah and I saw that they had
become a little bit of these scumbags
like the one day I wasn't paying
attention and the guy took me home on
the 105 mixing I was downtown LA why am
i downtown LA no there's not it's 9:15
the [ __ ] morning your tip is done I
gotta tell him your tip is gone I hope
you enjoy the [ __ ] $8 you tried to
rob for me cuz I usually throw you a
[ __ ] 20 spot now you get nothing for
being a [ __ ] dirty sneak you know you
got now I learned all about Reuben the
surcharges you can't [ __ ] around with
uber in certain times in New York they
will rape you oh yeah they will [ __ ] and
shove it up your ass and well deserved
listen it's it's AK economist it's
shortage of whatever it rains in New
York that surcharge goes up 40 bucks oh
yeah there was a couple nights out
that the [ __ ] fairy and I would go to
danger fields and they would say 50
bucks at 8:40 so I would sit there and
make phone calls till 905 and it would
go down to 31 dollars after 9:00 oh yeah
whenever they yeah they just raise but
it would at least like flip them with
them I always feel like it's the at
least they're up front that's the thing
that's that gets on my nerves - its
words when you feel like people are
trying to get something over on you
well that's what happened the last time
I took a cab and I always supported cabs
because I've been taking it for years
but after I got robbed this last time I
said [ __ ] it and I looked at what I paid
you don't like this uber X and there's
uber XL well I have luggage like that
new brakes out if I gotta go from third
Avenue to a tableau in 20 blocks to do
brakes I don't need no [ __ ] you know
I'm not gonna take a train I took one
[ __ ] train to Brooklyn I thought I
was gonna have a heart attack I thought
I was gonna have a heart attack guys I I
just listened you only be underground no
I don't have any problem with that [ __ ]
I'm from the underground I'm saying I'm
from the original underground I took
more trains than Johnny [ __ ] trains
but you're not used to it no more the
Train every time I get on this train you
feel for your life in 18 minutes on that
train ride to Brooklyn I actually feared
for my life ladies and gentlemen I'm not
gonna lie to you I actually felt around
in my pocket I had no keys I could stab
somebody with a hotel key for the first
time I didn't have [ __ ] a key in my
pocket I'm like how am I gonna fight one
of these attackers
I got no mace all I got to right kick to
the stomach and if that don't work I'm
done I have a heart attack some anxiety
of something's I attacked me I and I
went up there at 11:30 in the morning
and I felt unsafe first of all nobody
will give you directions just will not
give you directions got a little
information box they've lowered the
volume to [ __ ] with you like excuse me I
got to get off on 65th Street in
Brooklyn the guy talked like he had a
[ __ ] something up his ass and he like
whispering to me like it was a mob like
I was in the [ __ ] mafia something
like this I know can you speak up first
now I was petrified so before I did
take information for somebody you don't
trust him yeah you know many times I
gave out fake information in my life
people come up to me where's Caleb C
Street and I'd send them to [ __ ]
Delaware these people in these boxes I
did not trust for one minute they were
looking me up and down like and they
would I felt that they were sending me
on a train to I get robbed or something
so though I only took the train one day
I got a call from the movie people I go
listen it's an easy train right I go you
know what what's a [ __ ] train right
uncle Joey right it was like a six block
walk I didn't mind that that I didn't
mind but once I went downstairs it's a
complete different [ __ ] world
you ever see the original Planet of the
Apes there's a movie called beneath the
Planet of the Apes it came on 1971 or 72
they are going they all lived under the
trains there was something to do under
the [ __ ] trains where the people rip
their skins off their faces and they
were Martians so they were [ __ ]
whatever in that it was them against the
Apes let me tell you some I felt like
one of these people were about to rip
their face off when I get then with the
[ __ ] weirdest looking people in the
world people looking for money some guy
throwing on the [ __ ] floor you could
smell piss by the time you're there you
see a thousand [ __ ] rats on the train
track and you took this son every two
hours you're looking at a post and you
could see things moving like it's like
did I do a [ __ ] edible a 10:30 in the
morning no I didn't and then you realize
[ __ ] that's right those are rats down
there let me stay a little bit away from
the [ __ ] thing Jesus so I get on the
[ __ ] train and right I'm on the train
there's a guy excuse me you know I got
AIDS I got an ingrown toenail I got back
acne you know there was another guy
playing the [ __ ] organ it was I fear
from everybody on the train look angry I
can hear something bad coughing with
bronchitis I could feel the bronchitis
creeping in on my thing I had to get off
walk a little bit and then get on
another train and what I did was I
called the friend of mine that was in
his office and I made him look up you
know he take strangely takes other
different type of trains like in
Manhattan and I called him up and he
carved it out for me and thank God I got
to the location
when I walked above and I saw Brooklyn I
said I'm never taking a train again like
my daughter
to go on the train I don't know no more
like I don't know that was just [ __ ]
crazy on that [ __ ] train LA and no
better they stabbed somebody yesterday
at the Echo Park station did it really
yeah it was on the news somebody was
saying it yesterday when I came back I
won't know where the subconscious cuz it
was sadly I came I had to go to some
class with the baby and I figured they
had to take a shower and [ __ ] traffic
let me take a [ __ ] drive and see
what's cracked on a neighborhood told by
subconscious and I was telling them I
got I got on a train for the adventure
and it was the adventure of death like I
was [ __ ] scared when I got out not to
lie to you people you know I tell you
how to [ __ ] it is when I came above that
ground that was like move I [ __ ] made
it without getting raped I mean it cuz
that's what I felt like we got like they
were gonna surround me and [ __ ] rape
me on their [ __ ] train buzzes now was
it through the [ __ ] giant beside that
I got the full [ __ ] experience man I
took the ferry I got to smell the Hudson
River it still smells horrible
how are the hot dogs I only had one
that's it one that was it add one on
wardrobe day I stopped some [ __ ] Arab
I said seven right he looked at me like
I called him a [ __ ] Islam he put the
[ __ ] Sabourin on with the onions I
ate it bless it something's not right he
was a nice guy we talked for a little on
everything it's just not the it's not
the same I had it the first week I was
there I didn't I can't tell you I went
off my diet but you know when I went to
the the first day on the set and all
right sir descent had tremendous food
but I didn't eat salami the whole time I
was they had no cold cuts if I would eat
a slice of peach anything with a [ __ ]
salad I kept I drank nothing but water I
didn't even drink [ __ ] diet soda but
the only thing I drank that was sugar
and it was kombucha that was it just to
clean my system out cuz you got the
Hudson River water going into everyday
cleaning you out I stuck to it guys I
[ __ ] stuck to my weight watcher
points I like I said I went to inform
Fitness on 51st Street across the street
there was Giuseppe's or somethings pizza
cusamano's pizza I would lift and I
would go across the street get a slice
with a salad and then I would make
myself walk 12 or 15 [ __ ] blocks and
then I saw how I felt I'm gonna take an
uber the rest of the way or I would just
walk home - whatever hotel I was staying
I started I stayed at three different
[ __ ] the hotels in three weeks really
the first thing I said the Williams
hotel which was great on 39th and
[ __ ] third it was a great hotel clean
[ __ ] coffee and [ __ ] like that it was
an English themed hotel and they didn't
have breakfast in the building and you
had to walk two blocks to get [ __ ]
breakfast and you know yeah you can make
coffee in the room and I would get up
and ride through my early writing I had
a vapor pen which guess what guys I'm
done with vapor pens
really yeah they don't do nothing to me
my it's it's in the morning for two or
three days after that I could sit there
like Pocahontas what on Abby's pipe and
nothing [ __ ] happens to me so I'm
really done with vapor pens I brought it
out to the half a [ __ ] weed I brought
an ounce of this cake something that was
27% and I I wanted a space out the weed
so I only smoked two joints a day I
smoked the bat in the morning before I
got in the van to shoot and I smoked the
bat ran out of the [ __ ] set before I
got back in the van and I would get
[ __ ] wasted how much did he bring
back
no I said the last joint I smoked the
last joint before I got him the [ __ ]
Hoover to the airport oh [ __ ] it worked
out perfectly I spread out I'm a [ __ ]
Mountain Dog I'm Jerry [ __ ] he is I
add it to the tea and people gave me
wheat like when I went to the theater in
Minneapolis and Milwaukee the guy gave
me an eighth of weally bought in
Colorado I gave that to my friend George
and then my hello buddy gave me a bag of
weed that his friend had grown I gave
that a well he smoked away that problem
Thanks I didn't want to smoke anything
else and it lasted me I smoked the last
bazooka on that don't get me wrong I
roll some big [ __ ] joints yeah I roll
some [ __ ] fingers don't get me wrong
I spoke to the ounce in two weeks I got
when I got back from the walkie I
cracked into the ounce and I smoked the
same weed for two weeks like I tell you
it was [ __ ] tremendous I mean the
whole trip was tremendous guys it's
amazing how scared we get when
something's gonna be good
how [ __ ] scared we get all I kept
thinking about was when I started Tommy
how
scan I was like how scared I was to get
on [ __ ] stage and once I did it it
changed everything and this trip changed
everything for me it changed my outlook
on things like I said the beginning it
rejuvenizer me I did the baldy no
podcast but that was great I loved Carlo
and I love Bo but while I was doing it I
knew I didn't belong there like I was
like I shouldn't be doing any [ __ ]
podcast I'm gonna take a break from
podcast and that's exactly what I did I
took a break from podcasting for 10 days
19 days and it just felt great guys and
I mean you're like Joey what the [ __ ]
listen man we all need a break from time
to time we don't know it we don't even
know it which we got a head so far up
our [ __ ] asses that we don't even
know when it's time to take a break or
breathe it and then when it happens
you're like man I really [ __ ] me that
this you know the last thing I [ __ ]
thought I could do was leave my family I
love that little girl with all my
[ __ ] heart guys I didn't wanted to
fall into a bad situation or something I
got a tape man it was the best thing for
us in our home you know it showed him
work value on my part it shows I'm not
scared on my part
you know I face whatever time with them
every day
I spoke to her every day before she went
to school I made it a [ __ ] point to
call before she went to school the same
thing I do and talk to when I tell her
before we get off don't let nobody mess
with you today oh and I taught it to her
at night and it was just uh it was just
great it was just something different
something new you know I guess I gotta
go back next week for six days and yes I
am looking forward to it
I get to wrap this [ __ ] great
opportunity that I got offered to me by
the grace of God and I got another
breather
I got another breather to walk around
this time I'm gonna go to my mother's
cemetery I got to go to Union City and
walk around a little bit
I'm gonna go cats to see that kid I
didn't even have a Cuban sandwich didn't
even have a Cuban Center that's how much
I watched and what I hate because I know
how you blow up
then you blow up quick no sweets
whatsoever one of the nights I took a
flan and I ate half of it and I threw
the rest of it in the garbage that was
the only sweet I had in nineteen [ __ ]
days no sweets at all I had a chocolate
thing on JetBlue mint like a
[ __ ] always taking care of uncle
Joey they have expresso that's why I fly
JetBlue mint because they give you
expressing they give you a little dark
chocolate which is very good for you
from time to time so that's the only
sweet that's the only [ __ ] sugar I
hate this week I'm gonna watch it
then I'll go shoot and then when I come
back with the pieces for were there man
back to salami sandwiches at night but
for right now I gotta watch this cuz you
look good on camera you don't want to
look [ __ ] bloated I mean the second
day I was there there was a point in the
hotel room that I pissed every 15
minutes for three hours while I had like
from those three flights I got there
from Newark that Monday I didn't do [ __ ]
and I went out I did a bunch of little
errands around New York I had a mail
some stuff and do [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Monday I was in my hotel room from 3 to
7 in from 3 to 5 I pissed every 15
minutes and it was 3 to 4 minute pisses
my body had retained so much [ __ ]
water from the flights even my water
pills didn't you know but what I did was
that Monday when I got back I didn't do
much but I lifted I want up to inform
fitness and I lifted and that forced all
that [ __ ] fluid I had out of me which
felt and when I got the Easter Sunday
Chinese food so to top off the [ __ ]
the three plane rides and me retaining
water
I had the [ __ ] Chinese food and that
really put me over the [ __ ] top so
Monday my old [ __ ] Cuban ass I was
just pissing I was ready to call the
[ __ ] 9-1-1 to come get me because I
thought I was just going to dehydrate
there on the spot
I wasn't even thirsty it was just my
body was holding so much [ __ ] fluid
in it that it was uh it was [ __ ] life
change you know I'm saying it's funny I
got a call when I was in New York the
other day from a friend of mine you look
at opportunities you know Here I am a
shooting the soprano I'm gonna tell you
guys a little story I got hit in 97 and
I was doing okay you know getting spots
I mean I wasn't lighting the world on
fire I was hustling I was doing the
Mexicans room with Felipe Willie Barcena
Gabriel all those guys and I was trying
to pick up momentum right after 9/11
right before 9/11 I got a call one day
from rich Williams he's a writer we were
with the same manager and he goes I got
a new gig it's working for the best damn
sports show and they want to do sketches
and I want to bring you in so you do
regular sketches so he brought me the
first time they like me so they called
me I'm gonna gave me a shooting schedule
I thought I was gonna light the world on
fire I was making 150 dollars a show no
nothing that's nothing epple I was gonna
get like 2,000 oh when I got the call
I'm like that's gotta be 2000 it's Fox
Sports and [ __ ] they gonna give me some
of that Frank Caliendo money they gave
us Frank was already established on Fox
Sports I get to the [ __ ] thing Brody
Stevens got restless souls on is the
warm-up rich is there you know couple
others so I got into the rotation I must
have done over 50 [ __ ] sketches and
just to let you know guys how life is
you know I must have done 50 sketches
for these guys and all of a sudden this
comic from Boston moved to town very
Italian this comic he came from Boston
with a bad reputation
I never judged him I didn't really care
I had a mission to go on and he hit the
town like a [ __ ] animal I can't even
describe it to you guys he hit the town
like something I never saw before I
thought I was finished I'm like whatever
little Heath I had going on this kid has
taken away my [ __ ] heat not only was
he gonna get in spots at the store Jim
masala was giving him spots The Improv
was give him spots
he was the hot kid in town this one out
for about a year and a half and went on
so long that one day get so violent the
best damn sports show and I went to Fox
and pitched him an idea and like a month
later this guy was doing my idea on Fox
now if you know anything about my Kelly
got up to the guy and said something I
didn't talk to the producers I pitched
over again they kept calling me with
some [ __ ] story I never picked up
the phone for them again and eventually
I just stopped working there this guy
had taken my thunder from me I never
said nothing to the guy I knew the guy
had personal problems I had heard things
I wasn't jealous I wasn't angry I just
knew something you haven't know
something like you just know I didn't
wish nothing bad on the guy anything I
just knew something I knew that I would
outlast him I knew that if I kept my
peas and my cues that I would outlast
and he got a television deal he was
around town bragging and by the time I
got the lung then I started picking up a
little momentum after The Sopranos bah
bah bah bah bah bah and he moved away
something happened though I the TV show
then go and now I heard he was in Vegas
and every time I would hear about him
it's how good he was doing in Vegas he
was the king of Vegas he had seven
nights a week going at this casino and
people were showing up he was making all
types of money was i jealous along no I
was doing my own thing by that time but
something didn't seem right you know I
kept plugging along and didn't think of
anything about it
I started getting you know my name is
Errol and there was a strike and I stand
up Bob and I thought about quitting
stand-up he was still doing great you
know in Vegas I saw him in a UFC event
he walked up to me with a egotistical
[ __ ] smile that he had but meanwhile
he had done a bunch of little bad things
here and there which again I did worse
things by do them in my youth I wasn't
doing them as a comic and I don't know
maybe five years ago a friend of mine
calls and he goes did you look on
Facebook what's going on in Vegas with
this kid and I went on Facebook and I
found the article and it was just
overwhelming the poor kid had a bad bad
gambling problem he had just a bad game
from that followed him from Boston to LA
and the Vegas now you know I mean it's
like me moving to Miami when I have my
coke problem you're just going there to
die you know you're just going there to
[ __ ] die it's a bad decision this guy
decided to move to Vegas and yeah even
though he was making money he was
borrowing money but I mean borrowing
money from people like Lee give me
thirty thousand oh my god and people
give him thirty thousand ten thousand
some old lady gave him sixty thousand
you know he was a he had the gift of gab
you can't blame it on the guy if you're
gonna go for money go for it if you ask
ten people for $50,000 to him we're
gonna give him Dean you know that's the
law again eventually that's why I was
here you go up to your friend with a
good story they'll give it to you and he
took all their money he had a tax lien
on him and then all these people went to
a newspaper and wrote this [ __ ] and they
wrote this big article in the Vegas
newspaper about this kid and I felt bad
for the kid I felt bad for the kid
because once I got into comedy the only
thought with me was cocaine and I kept
it to a minimum I still didn't interfere
it did not interfere with my comedy I
did my comedy first and I took care my
drug business later it wasn't like they
were going back and forth yeah I sold
coke to people from time to time at the
club and I point eight walls together
but it didn't affect me from doing my
[ __ ] job it did but it didn't I was a
functioning addict okay let's listen
even at that so they put the article the
paper about this guy and bla bla bla bla
bla bla guess what they keep giving them
jobs he keep you know it was smaller
gambling venues kept giving him jobs and
when I was in New York I got a call from
a dear friend of mine from Boston and he
goes I just wanted to tell you something
I did a gig west where he can guess
who's back in town I don't know
ain't told me this kid not
no they chase him out of Vegas and he
goes yeah and he's here in town saying
that he's gonna open up 11 comedy club
but he's already bounced a bunch of
checks well and you know guys I felt
like how was it by no means am i happy
by somebody else's no means I'm at an
age now where I don't it doesn't even
bother me I feel bad I feel bad for
Jesse Smollett I feel bad for a lot of
people we had we [ __ ] around and crack
jokes but I kind of feel bad for him
that at this age which is my age he's
still pulling that same thing and I
gotta tell you something guys which
would mean you he was a great comic he
was a phenomenal improviser and he could
have turned out to be 20 times the comic
that I am Co Vaughn is you know triple e
this guy could have been [ __ ] huge
today but because he didn't take care of
that problem you know he he let his
character ruin his [ __ ] destiny you
know what I had a bad [ __ ] drunk bomb
all the time
thought it was 44 years old and
something hit me like a bolt of
lightning one day and before the grace
of God here we [ __ ] are and I haven't
done a [ __ ] line in 12 [ __ ] years
and I'm very thankful yeah I do my
[ __ ] edibles I'm back on the animals
by the way inedible before I got on a
JetBlue flight right I had a switch
flights
you know me I'm an [ __ ] I was done
and I switched flights I took a later
flight I had my own little box mint mint
and I could take the [ __ ] animal as I
get to the airport I take a water from
mint and right on the TSA line I pop one
of those hundred milligrams that's
killing [ __ ] as I walked
through I can feel my heartbeat
there's annex to come this Tiger and my
buddy gave me two of them when I saw him
in New York so I had one in my pocket
and I broke it in half and inhaled half
of it I saved the other half when I got
off the plane so I can get home and go
to sleep I got out of the plane you know
me I put on my [ __ ] the iPod and I
start off with [ __ ] super run no
and the plane was delayed but they took
off from the gate in time it just kept
you know driving and it drove around for
like 20 minutes and the [ __ ] I don't we
were in Kansas I'm [ __ ] stoned to the
gills and all of a sudden like the
[ __ ] half-hour mark the pilot says
that listen there's a lot of weather
problems in the Midwest we don't know if
we'll be able to take off tonight
don't let it snow they're gonna pull
over to the side of the road there was a
bunch of planes on the side going Bias
they had been ok cuz they were flying
south planes that were flying west wall
on hold because of the bad weather in
the Midwest was tornadoes or some [ __ ]
now I'm starting to think maybe I should
have stayed on my plane made of his
[ __ ] planes when I go down when I
start panicking the THC takes me to a
place I'm thinking this planes gonna go
down I'm thinking about my funeral
you ready your will I'm thinking about
my cemetery I'm thinking about
everything I'm like oh my god I'm never
gonna see my family my friends my
daughter again this plans gonna go down
and I'm like what do I do I go hopefully
they'll cancel this flight and I'll get
back on my original flight and [ __ ] it
[ __ ] though about 20 minutes later pilot
comes on he goes we'll leave it not my
little fat heart is beating up a storm I
start farting the whole [ __ ] good the
blame takes off and I'm on JetBlue
you've got movies TV and DirecTV so I'm
thinking I'm doing the sign of the Cross
I'm playing I'm praying to every God to
exist
I [ __ ] press the button for DirecTV
and I see CNN headlines and I pressed
that oh no and the first article that
comes up is playing goes down in Florida
Friday night a plane went down from
Guantanamo from Cuba and right away I
was happy I go what are the chances of
two planes going down on one night you
know saying [ __ ] it I'm good and after
that the [ __ ] high went away and I
was fine to go that's not where I would
have gone Oh God
oh my god I was petrified that THC trip
took me to a dark place thank God you
started farting when you get nervous
yeah I started flying I fought when I'm
nervous and that is not foreign so it's
just really weird that this kid had all
the potential to be in this movie that
I'm in
and 20 other [ __ ] things but he let
his gambling get in his way you know a
couple weeks ago I went to see shinu
with my daughter the Saturday before we
left she likes all that Chinese stuff
and she want me to go see she's Shenyang
I don't know if I told you guys the
story I'm sitting there next in between
my daughter and my wife their seats
everywhere I'm looking towards my left
and all of a sudden something hits the
chair next to me like a [ __ ] meteor
like football and I turn around hisses
lady
I got no reason why either you shoot my
400 [ __ ] pounds she did not fit in
that [ __ ] chair she was [ __ ] that
was fat coming out of everywhere now
again I didn't judge where I felt bad
for her she was there with her mother
and there was a seat next to my wife and
she kept trying to hit if I can move to
that seat so she could put a mother
there like a listen I'm gonna sit in my
[ __ ] chair you know I'm not [ __ ]
moving for your mom she was a real pain
in the ass to someone but eventually my
wife said do you want me to sit there
and I'll sit yep I'll switch with you so
I went and switched she was a few years
younger than me she was about 400 pounds
she had a cane and she was there with
her mom and she was talking to my wife
and I was listening to the conversation
about her being on disability cause of
her weight that she's trying every diet
ba ba ba ba ba ba that she was a
schoolteacher but her knees were that
would bother her so much she had to use
a cane and the whole thing and here she
is a 50-something year-old woman she's
single she's at this play with her mom
that her mom had to buy her the ticket
for her to come there she's living just
to survive on this disability check
where she could be a teacher and it
really hit me a weird way because it hit
me - the fact that his his lady that
could have had a life if she just lost a
little bit of weight like if she just
tried to lose a little bit of weight she
would have had a [ __ ] life she would
have had a husband she would have had
kids she wouldn't have to be in a
[ __ ] play on a Sunday with a mom
not that isn't stuff nothing wrong with
that but do you guys understand what I'm
going for
she let this one thing getting her way
and take her down like she's already
done with her life she's 50 something
years old unless she goes like on a
[ __ ] huge huge diet
she's never gonna have the life that a
normal girl it wasn't that she was a
bad-looking girl anything if this girl
would have dropped 200 pounds when she
was 28 and focused on it she still would
have been teaching she wouldn't have had
a [ __ ] ceiling and come on of
disability and she would have had what's
called a [ __ ] life which is the
reason why we do what the [ __ ] we do
every day for years I struggled with a
[ __ ] addiction that held me back and
held me back thank God that I watched
the movie ray and somewhere along the
line they said that he had struggled
with heroin he was 60 years old let I'm
going if I have to do this to him 60 I'm
just not it's gonna be a waste of my
[ __ ] life you know I woke up one day
I was 418 pounds and I said I gotta do
something bad I walked into a Weight
Watchers I'm so happy I did because I
avoided the diabetes I avoided all the
pains and makes it going I'm still a fat
[ __ ] I'm still 60 pounds away but it's a
lot better than being 200 pounds
overweight the 300 pounds oh boy this
poor lady
let her wait ruin her [ __ ] life
whether it's weight an opiate problem
you know gambling gambling [ __ ]
insecurities you're letting these things
hold you back from having a [ __ ] life
what a shitty way to [ __ ] go you're
gonna be sitting there in a [ __ ] bed
a week away from the dying thinking
about all the things you wanted to do
but you didn't because you let something
hold you [ __ ] down I couldn't imagine
being that comic and Boston today and
still playing the games I was playing in
1995 in 1998 in 2003 where I was always
in the hustle and always in the chase
and lying to get a 20 and a 40 of a 60
and lying to my wife by just doing
cocaine it
such a [ __ ] relief I don't care what
you got going on with your life if you
got something in your life that's
stopping you from making your life be
that much a little better attack it
attack it listen I'm not saying you're
gonna win completely but I'd rather
drink two shots of vodka then ten
bottles of vodka week I much rather eat
two Oreos than a whole bag Oreos and two
[ __ ] nights I'd much rather you know
for a year I [ __ ] didn't do edibles I
didn't like two or three times you saw
me here for five years eat I'm Norma's
amount edibles and one day I said
something isn't right it's holding his
back it's holding me back and there you
go there you're [ __ ] gone when a year
we've made so much [ __ ] progress and
yeah I hate some edibles when I was back
in New York to help me sleep because the
time change I brought edibles with me
it's fine they're not consuming who the
[ __ ] I am I didn't in that way yesterday
I'm not thinking about eating one today
and I got a few of them left at the
[ __ ] house but it's these little
things if they're not gonna let you get
to hold a [ __ ] you are think about that
whether it's opiate whether it's pills I
mean there's a church listening today is
the memorial for a son crystal in Austin
who used to date Bobby Shannon with the
kobracast podcast my heart goes out to
128 years old the son they found him
dead 10 years ago ten days ago it's been
bothering me I called the last weekend I
you know I I hit her up on I'm [ __ ] I
had a message because her and I'd were
messing it because the t-shirts you know
when I went away I didn't take Facebook
with me and the only Twitter I had was
on my [ __ ] phone I didn't have no
social media in the hotel at all I
didn't want it I wanted to take a
[ __ ] break from it Bobby called me
and said and I thought about it 20 years
old that could have been me when I
kidnapped Bella a bullet could have gone
off and hit me in the leg and I would
have cut an artery or something I could
have bled out all the things that could
have happened it's not what I'm dwelling
on today what I'm talking about is if
you have something
that isn't let you be will you strive to
be just work on it a little bit I'm not
telling you to quit I know how hard it
is to get clean don't I [ __ ] know it
it took me twenty seven [ __ ] his it's
not gonna take you overnight either
thank God my fat little heart didn't
give up along the way there was a time
when my wife was [ __ ] tie my shoelaces
there was a time that if the elevator
was broken I would not go upstairs was
three flights of [ __ ] stairs
now listen I'm not flying upstairs and
I'm not running stairs at the LA
auditorium but at least I'm not huffing
and sucking puffing no more you know if
something's in your way it's an obstacle
of you becoming who you need to become
[ __ ] get it out of your way at least
push it a little bit just to the side
just for now just see you go around it
so you don't become a [ __ ] slave to
it like I did four years I'm not here to
tell you how to live here like I'm just
telling you what I see through my
[ __ ] eyes oh my god just when I was
packing to leave I thought about the
shoulder Sopranos I thought about how
that [ __ ] guy went to the producers
and told him that I told somebody and
all I send my mind switched I was like
how happy am i that he went to the
producers because at the end of the day
I wasn't ready I would've made a fool
out of myself even though I was here ten
years I've been already involved in
acting maybe three or four I've done a
few movies I was not ready for what
David Chase and high-level people had to
offer I just wasn't ready that today I
thank steve Schirripa with all my heart
for going through The Sopranos behind my
back because I got to work I got to the
original [ __ ] goal anyway and now
guess what now I'm ready for it now I
assume I absorbed it like a [ __ ]
sponge and I went in there and when you
guys watch the movie you're gonna go you
know what we're [ __ ] proud I'm gonna
make you proud that you put your money
on me that you bet on me that every week
even though I say the most [ __ ]
rudest things you believed in me
you know you come watch me you buy the
t-shirts we're a [ __ ] family
win for me is a win for you you're a
part of us not because you're a [ __ ]
fan of mine but because you believe you
send me messages you send me stuff in
the mail we've created something [ __ ]
great when I was when I would go home at
night after I would shoot this movie
yeah I would think about my daughter and
my wife but I thought a lot about you
guys and what you were gonna think about
it and how you've been listening for six
years and you've seen a change in
yourself and you've seen a change in me
this is what I I'm here to do a podcast
that I stand behind 150 percent every
week what I talk about on this podcast i
strictly bully you know i went home and
i saw one of my buddies when we were
talking about sushi and i go where do
you go for sushi it was I used to go to
that place but I found that there were
Koreans [ __ ] them
that's our mentality that's why I came
from I was happy that there's still
people who think like me I'm not a
[ __ ] Martian I came from a place
where it was class there was a little
respect North Bergen is a [ __ ] hole
you know but it's my home it's what
created me that New York City I saw two
[ __ ] rats when I was there I saw a
rat the first day and I saw a rat
Thursday night I saw a rat Thursday
night that looked like a [ __ ] cat in
Brooklyn not only was he big he stopped
me and looked at the vehicle like ahead
I dare you to hit me
you're [ __ ] Karl bent this thing look
like a [ __ ] like a little I saw skunk
- in North Bergen Saturday night night
when I was one of my childhood [ __ ]
friends I mean childhood childhood
childhood friends I was supposed to a
thousand things and he caught me out of
blue and he was a man I have time
tonight to go out to dinner with you
he's an assemblyman now and I said I've
got the W on one condition that we don't
talk politics and there's no [ __ ]
politicals around to [ __ ] bring me
down they go done so he went through his
restaurant Jersey City Court Alexander
steak house on the way back we went
[ __ ] we took the scenic route he
showed me all the accomplishments he had
done in North Bergen I'm very proud of
you know he took over Hudson County Park
he took over but he showed me what the
plans were for North Bergen in the
future you know and we
my mother's neighborhood we went to we
looked at the school all this on
Saturday night want more people jumping
up in that we wouldn't have a nice
[ __ ] dinner on the way back we just
drove we just drove 20 miles an hour we
drove he showed me with two guys well
the route I used to walk we drove by all
my friends houses to see how their
houses looked all the construction
that's happened in the last 30 years and
I got to see him I got to see George I
got the guat with a friend named tizzy I
got to see Timmy Holloway at the New
York Comedy Club I got to see some
comics I haven't seen in the round wild
Sara Tyler mash who might be on the show
next week and Bob bigger staff it really
what I'm happy that Tom Papa and
everybody else talked me out of my
[ __ ] fears if you get an opportunity
man and it feels right but your fear
takes over just do it for yourself take
a [ __ ] chance who gives a [ __ ]
anymore we're not taking chances
nothing's gonna happen for you in this
life nothing I took the biggest chance
of my life
you know I can't get into the
particulars about the movie and whatnot
but listen man take the [ __ ] chance
don't do what I did four years and a
thousand other people were scared and
making forward progress [ __ ] go for
it who gives a [ __ ] if you fail you're
gonna fail 80 times the thing is the
more you go the less to fail is every
year you get less failures in 82 you're
gonna have 21 failures you're jeeps
gonna blow up that's all part of life
what you're trying to do is keep the
failure rate down throughout the years
so there's no fuck-ups and pretty soon
you're running [ __ ] smooth because
you've already overtaken all these
[ __ ] failures they're coming you're
like things are gonna happen things
happened when I was in New York I didn't
make a big deal about how to migraine
headache for four days nobody had a
vicodin you know [ __ ] like that but you
just push forward I'm very happy I
accepted that role I'm very happy I went
to New York and I'm very happy that I
get to [ __ ] make you guys proud of me
and with that let me give you some dates
I'm going to do right now all I'm
[ __ ] pushing is June 6th but you know
June 7th at the Harrah's in New Orleans
and June 8 I'm at the Tabernacle
[ __ ] Theatre in Atlanta
[ __ ] Georgia how's that to you
[ __ ] then I got yet June 28th
29th I'm in Columbus for shows in and
out no [ __ ] drama and the full
schedule will be out mid-may and what's
left for the rest of the year I'm not
gonna do much just a couple weeks here
in there just to keep [ __ ] loose or
whatever thank you very much for letting
me ramble today about my experience the
whole time I was there I thought about
you guys and I thought about how I
almost [ __ ] turned down the project
to be a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
thought about how bad I would feel for
you guys if I would have turned it down
because of my [ __ ] fears no be scared
of nothing and never be scared and
moving forward now for a word from our
sponsors I want to talk to you people
buy something that's very important to
me and that's CBD or you wanna find a
reliable CBD company but they're all
over the [ __ ] place
everybody's got a CB deal you don't know
what you're buying that's like the
ginseng explosion of the 80s you
probably buying [ __ ] dick with CBD
line you know what the [ __ ] you're
buying why because before you even spend
a dollar you're gonna go on their
website CBD lion calm and look at their
test results their third-party test lab
results yourself they're the real deal
I've been involved with them for about
[ __ ] three months now and I love them
I reached out to them that's how [ __ ]
good I like the product the product you
understand me so picking a reliable
company is like pulling teeth but that
day is over cuz uncle Joey is here to
the [ __ ] rescue looking for you
[ __ ] I found CBD line and now you
find CBD lines they make CBD Lyon
products from start to finish and they
got you covered with the tension of the
vapor the shadow the [ __ ] that
depends I mean they got vapor pens and
if you look at all the causes that the
symptoms that it takes care of your
[ __ ] jaw dropped come on you're good
the gummies are good this is the way to
go for your CBD products CBD line that
comes in paper cartridges shatta you
know eat a gummy
I mean you could put it under your
tongue their products are clean Bobby
and they are like the fakes that with
the false [ __ ] advertising CBD line
is the
way to go you check out their
third-party test results for yourself
now the church family gets 20% or 20%
not 10 not 15 not bad 20% off a checker
by using codename shirts that CBD lion
calm the best in the business and they
got something you can rub on your
shoulders you can rub you on your
nutsack I don't give a [ __ ] what you do
CBD lion is there for you again go to
CBD lion calm
do not forget May 12th is Mother's Day
don't be a schmuck without your mother
you'd be nothing you understand me
do not forget where would you be without
your mom know where you'd be in a toilet
somewhere that sure you'd be flown
ProFlowers is here to help you show your
appreciation this year my wife Tara
she's getting two dozen of these you
understand me beautiful red roses they
come in a beautiful package you have
your card in there whatever now you want
to do beautiful ProFlowers let you
choose from a variety of bouquets and
vices that suit every mom style all you
gotta do is pick the delivery date
whether you wanna get in there day
earlier or our mother day then men
ProFlowers carefully packages your
flowers and delivers them fresh from the
farm smelling tremendous your wife opens
up that box your mom your sister
whatever mom you have in your life throw
flowers is the way to go
express delivery means her flowers stay
fresh and that's what you're looking for
you understand me so right now you get a
dozen assorted roses for your ravenous
1999 a day to find a cheaper $19.99 if
you find a cheaper those roses will be
dead in three hours so that she gets
them no just go along like olive oil you
don't want that you want a nice roses
beautiful roses and if you double the
roses you got a premium vazh for just
$9.99 more we do think what you're gonna
get those prices at Uncle Joe he always
saves the day even Mother's Day you
understand me so visit proflowers.com
right now you click the microphone on
the upper right hand corner and enter
the promo code happening h AP PE ni ng
that's proflowers.com click the
microphone and use the code happening
blow flowers is here to help you this is
gonna make it
it's an easy for you whether you like
your mother or not like they're gonna be
gonna be like you send the flowers and
you show up with more flowers or candy
if you don't like to send the flowers
you need to show up at least you don't
have to feel guilty about yourself
Mother's Day is May 12th it's May 5th
I'm giving you seven days to work it out
on May 6 tomorrow I'm giving you
whatever it is 8 9 I don't know what I'm
one of my mathematician just know the
proflowers.com right now click the
microphone in the upper right hand
corner and enter promo code church order
like a pro and get this amazing rose
deal to thank all the moms in your life
so I want to thank CBD Lyon I want to
thank ProFlowers but most importantly I
want to thank you savages for always
listening
it's Monday mother [ __ ] grab your
balls and let's look forward it's a
whole new [ __ ] horizon and you
guys are part of it like I said June 7th
the Fillmore at New Orleans
it's your type of place Harris and June
8th I'm at the Tabernacle you're gonna
[ __ ] love it you understand me in
Columbus on the 28th and 29th I want to
thank you I want to take your families I
want to thank all you [ __ ] for
supporting the church I want to thank
the [ __ ]
for always being here and that's it and
that's that I'll see you Thursday
morning nice and [ __ ] early tip-top
Magoo
have a great week uncle Joey loves you
kick this [ __ ] melee